الطعام امر شخصي للغايه واعتقد انه عندما
نشعر الناس بالعار او مشاعر الذم بين
الافراد فهذا عاده يكون طريقا صعبا للغايه
لان ذلك يمكن ان يجلب معه الكثير من الغضب
وردود الفعل القويه جدا مما مثلا الفيغام
فوبيا
بعد اخذ قسط من الراحه اعادوا تجميع
صفوفهم هذه المره استعدادا للاحتجاج على
استخدام الفراء من قبل احد المتاجر
الراقيه في لندن
يجول الناشطون هؤلاء في شوارع لندن مره او
مرتين او حتى عده مرات امام المتاجر التي
يقولون بانها تستخدم اساليب تنتهك حقوق
الحيوانات في انتاج الملابس
قد يقال الكثير عن النباتيه لكن الاكيد
انها ليست توجها جديدا فالنباتيه اسلوب
حياه ظهر في حضارات وطبعا فلسفات عده على
مر التاريخ ولكن مع بروز انماط جديده
للحياه تركز على النظام الصحي وتحارب
التدهور المناخي بدات النباتيه تاخذ طابع
الحركه السياسيه الشامله التي برزت فيها
تيارات اكثر تشددا
ازدادت شعبيه الحركات المناصره للنباتيين
في بريطانيا في الاونه الاخيره امر متوقع
مع ارتفاع اعداد نباتيين بنسبه
360% في غضون 10 سنوات خلال العقد الماضي
ولكن ما مدى تاثير استهلاك اللحوم على
البيئه
وجدت دراسه ان النظام الغذائي العالمي
مسؤول عن 21 الى 37% من انبعاثات الغازات
الدافئه فيما استهلاك اللحوم يعد سببا
رئيسيا الانبعاثات غازات الميثان وثاني
اكسيد الكربون واكسيد النيتروز هذه
الغازات تسهم في تغير المناخ مثل الاحتباس
الحراري وتربيه المواشي تعد في طليعه
الاسباب التي ترفع نسبه هذه الغازات
والحل بحسب الدراسه التحول الى نظام نباتي